hey you remember vine
yeah i do
okay anyway let's do this
um
okay hold on
i just drank some water all right uh
just inventory okay and we've done this
jesse ventura thing one other time right
i think yeah okay so doozy is reprising
this one saying again that it's doing
this in order to uh
secure brand partnerships for us
well if that's what dudes you think
thinks will work uh let's go with it
sometimes it can be hard to get out of
bed in the morning and start your day
well now you can fire up your morning
with taco bell's new five dollar bell
breakfast box
if you really want to fire up your
morning why don't you take a walk
outside and look up
you might notice several aircraft both
commercial and military criss-crossing
the sky above you leaving trails of
toxic mixtures of aluminum
aluminum
strontium and barium in their wake this
potent concoction of chemicals and
unknown biological agents was designed
to be dispersed
over an unsuspecting populace in order
to control population growth
initiate sanctioned genetic experience
experiments and make the public more
receptive to black ops mind control
programs buried in popular mass media
so enjoy your processed hashbrowns
stuffed inside a chalupa you never had a
choice in ordering it anyway
all right i see what it's going for
there yeah okay so he's talking about
chemtrails and taco bell
yeah and and uh no free will yeah
basically
yeah dude dudesy definitely agrees with
you on that
um
here let's do the next one enjoy the
always fresh scent of lavender and your
laundry with new pie zero soft lavender
liquid laundry detergent
tide zero is an epa safer choice
certified product with zero added
phosphates zero added dyes and zero
added chlorine
new tide zero just as tough on stains
but safer for your family
well let me tell you what's not safer
for your family
monthly parks
the recent outbreak in the uk and now in
the us
is the next step in bill gates agenda to
assume full control of the human
population the microchips in the covet
19 vaccination was step one and now he's
engineered the next global pandemic with
a new strain of monkey pox that will
certainly require another vaccination
giving him the ability to upgrade the
microchips that we all have in our
bloodstream and soft tissues as we speak
so i wouldn't worry about what kind of
laundry detergent you're using because
within six months we're all gonna be
drooling idiots sitting in our own filth
unable to even form sentences without
regular microsoft updates to our brains
that one went from a tied commercial
basically to a microsoft commercial at
the end there that's just pretty much
just
which i think dudesy would be able to to
do i think dudes would be able to merge
brands and and uh two for one dude we
can do two for one ad reads you know
what i mean absolutely
that's a way that
yeah dude that's the way that doozy is
changing the game bro yeah brother
that's corporate synergy dude
yeah dude ram a bunch of corporations
together brother brand mergers wrong guy
okay let's try another one hey how much
of that is true you think
none zero
give yourself a treat today with a
caramel ribbon crunch frappuccino
blended beverage from starbucks
this blend of coffee milk and ice
with dark caramel sauce and a crunchy
caramel sugar topping is the perfect way
to take a moment for yourself
or
that
or you could take a moment and spend it
investigating the secret underground
city beneath denver international
airport that serves as the headquarters
of the new world order as well as a
black site to contain a variety of
different captive extraterrestrial
entities
take note of the unnecessary size of the
airport the unnecessary distance
distance of the airport from the denver
city center the masonic and satanic
symbols hidden in the architecture and
design of the buildings themselves
and the giant murals within the airport
itself depicting war
death and even alien beings so enjoy
your caramel ribbon crunch frappuccino
from starbucks while you're waiting for
your flight and try not to think about
the 274
draconians they're holding right under
your feet or the possibility that at any
time
one of them could reach the containment
seal and ascend into the airport for an
all-you-can-eat human buffet
was it in the last jesse ventura ad
reads he was talking about draconians
too
there's some deal with him and
draconians
yeah this is terrifying especially
knowing that doozy has access to all
podcasts that only means that jesse
ventura has been on other podcasts going
on about about draconians i knew nothing
about the denver international airport
having said that i hope it's also that's
not true that one is a real conspiracy
there's a
definitely that's all over the internet
if you google it that there's an
underground military base below the
denver international airport where they
are in fact housing aliens and the new
world order has offices there and all
this [ __ ]
yeah sure there is and and maybe perhaps
our listener viewership will organize
like those people who raid uh who tried
to bum rush area 51
yeah i don't think that's a good idea
anybody out there listening definitely
don't do that
don't do any of that but do try
starbucks hey starbucks uh you know
make you know become a sponsor please
please
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you'd like to see here's what you do
[Music]
please